Peyton Manning is accepted the all-in
challenged with a round of golf and
dinner being auctioned off for charity
the winner and two friends will play a
round of golf with the two-time Super
Bowl champ followed by dinner with ten
of their closest friends more on this
with Peyton Manning the all-in challenge
am I eligible for this Peyton
sure you are Dan I was thinking about
throwing you into the package and see if
that increased the value of it maybe
maybe in the fourth quarter of the
auction I'll add that in okay if you
need me if you need me for a little help
bring me in from the bullpen are you fun
playing golf with I think I am I mean
that's kind of why I play golf is to
have fun I enjoy playing with with good
people you know about there's my
brothers and dad or my teammates just
buddies here from college or whatever
maybe that's kind of what it's about for
me to have some laughs and to put the
phone down and to get away so that's
kind of my thought about doing was you
know creating something where we can
have some fun have lots of laughs and
you know go to dinner at a local
restaurant in that person's hometown
maybe support it if they've been
struggling and tell some stories and
like I said Houston for maybe having
them have a memorable day and evenings
have you played golf with Michael Jordan
I never have I never had I know how much
he loves to play I never got the chance
to play with him I remember I saw
Michael Jordan at with two things the
first time I did a commercial really
ever kind of a national commercial was
after my second season in the NFL we had
a good year with the cold so I did a
commercial with Michael Jordan for
Gatorade and what I remember was the
first time I was introduced to a double
was which I your double for the
commercial was somebody to stand in
somebody it was the same height as you
kind of had a similar look I think
Jordan's doubled it's made of killing
doing all of Michaels commercials let me
travel wherever he was and so and he did
kind of look like them and I remember I
get there they go Oh Peyton your doubles
hair is a little shorter than you
do you mind if we cut your hair to match
your double and I was like isn't it
supposed to work the other way around
like the dog won't match me like would
you shave if you tell Jordan to shave
his mustache so that's kind of that's
kind of what I knew by the Jordan was
who he was and I was a little further
down the ladder I remember when we won
the Super Bowl in Indianapolis I saw
Michael at a golf tournament in
Charlotte and you know I was kind of I
guess I've kind of gotten used to
hearing sort of congratulations
congratulations great job to kind of all
that on that circuit I remember seeing
that for Jordan he should hey Peyton
congratulations you got a long way to
catch up thank you very much I thought
he would hold up a meal one hand like
five like you're five behind him he made
it very clear so it kept me humble which
is a good thing but the difference
between like you played golf with Tiger
right okay but that competitiveness in
Mike I don't know how people turn it on
and off for the competitiveness when you
play with Tiger is he competitive well I
mean it's the odds are kind of stacked
against me you know he doesn't the times
I play with Tiger he doesn't really like
to give shots and so he'd say like
what's your handicap I was like I'm a
nine and then I'll give you nine shots
and I'm like but you're not a zero he's
like yes I am
no you're not you're like a plus seven
right now I'll take 16 he's right now
I'll give you I'll give you nine I'm
like this is not you know so I mean we
can never get it figured out of the
first tee so therefore it really wasn't
much of a match we're talking to a
Peyton Manning the all-in challenge give
people more details on this and some
other people involved in this by the way
I saw where your brother's given away
the Corvette that he won at the Super
Bowl when he was the MVP I have the card
Peyton that I that says Eli because I
presented that to him I I was telling
you the story
whatever last week I don't know if the
person bidding on that once the actual
card
that says Eli Manning you've just won
this you're the MVP of this Super Bowl
but if absolutely okay because I should
be here yeah that's okay I'll figure out
how to get that to do you out of Leela's
going to present the car to the actual
winner so yes hope the winner is like in
Seattle Washington Eli has to travel all
the way out there and take to the ship
and out there yeah I mean I think he
thinks it's going to be in New York
somewhere you know some big diets and
but there's lots of Giants fans in
Seattle to here how about Hawaii yeah
exactly it's in the United State Hwy is
in play but yeah you know I guess when
you got to Super Bowl MVP cars you can
give one away but that's pretty cool
pretty allowed to do that and to give it
away a person and y'all in challenge
then it's put on by fanatics it's just
you know it's it's inspired by the ice
bucket challenge a couple years ago by
JJ Watts kind of fund he set up for the
hurricane in Houston and just a just a
chance for people all over the world to
contribute and to participate in kind of
a fun of them either because there's
raffle items there's a chance to be on a
Leonardo DiCaprio movie you can buy a
raffle ticket for ten dollars and you
might win the more raffle tickets you
buy maybe the better chance you have to
win or there's kind of pure auction item
sort of behind the ropes experiences I
think Tom Brady's offering
dinner with him after their first game
with the bunks and his game new jersey
and and cleats from that game Eli was
doing the car I'm doing golf this is
chance for athletes and actors to kind
of offer behind the ropes experiences
for people all over the world to bid on
and contribute all the money's going to
hunger program to feed kids you aren't
getting fed properly to see people who
are out of work they need food to
provide meals to frontline workers via
restaurants that need support so it's a
win-win all the way around and a lot of
people hurting out there's you know it's
so the more support we can give the
better off we'll be
how do you think social
these mock drafts would handle you
coming out of Tennessee when you did if
you if it was happening now I tell you
that's it that's that's something
everybody kind of needs to get ready for
coming out of course their one social
media then but I remember I remember
somebody telling me hey look just so you
know you're about to get picked on and
kind of broken down during this
pre-draft process that's just what they
do is they sort of point out all your
all your weaknesses and tell you the
things that you can't do and I remember
for me kind of the buzz word was he
doesn't have any upside I was like no
upside I'm 21 years old I mean I have to
have a room outside I mean you know I
mean my neck might get a little long
that's gonna grow and I think I probably
could get a little faster and quicker
because the bars pretty low and I could
put on some weight so I don't know I
mean that's just part of it I think
that's the norm and of course there's so
many outlets now and the last thing we
need is another draft analyst I mean I
thought mental Tibor always done the
best job and now he's got a bit others
50 other people trying to be Mel typer
nobody's going to get his hair of course
but there's a lot of analysis out there
so I think it's a relief to these
players when the draft finally gets your
damn because then you find out where
you're going to work where you going to
live and you can you can start that
process right away I remember when I got
drafted in New York I flew to
Indianapolis I got in my playbook I flew
back in Knoxville we had a little draft
celebration party and I was back in
Indianapolis a couple days later getting
ready for a mini cameras this is the
Wonderlic score man I don't really think
it does I didn't I can't remember what I
did all I remember Eli like had this
incredible score I think he had like you
know 42 or something but he I remember
these I came and spent a couple days
made in Indianapolis before the combine
and I remember when he actually took the
Wonderlic he told me he goes Peyton the
tests that I was studying last night at
your house was the exact
test that I got for the Wonderlic the
exactcast and so he made like 42 which
was awesome I think I made like I don't
know 23 or something and and so I'm like
that's awesome you know because the
tests are kind of out there there's no
doubt you're gonna get there's no
question there's no guarantee you'll get
the same one but you can new the sample
questions but Eli's kind of forgotten to
tell that story and all he says now is
how much smarter he is that homeless
people are smarter than Tennessee people
so wait you just sold him out here well
it's you know that's what brothers do
right statute of limitations is up I
have I have
Eli it's 39 and you at 28 okay there you
go so yeah he beat me and I mean how
about you Dan and how would you do that
I mean this is a question on my one to
look test you're 17 years old
your sister is you think okay I got it
yeah you're 17 years old your sister is
twice your age when you're 23 how old
will she be wait you're on the clock
here oh I know I know I know
so I'm 17 and and she's run that by me
again you're 17 years old your sister is
twice your age
okay you're 23 how old she be okay so
she's 34 and she would be 40 now she's
always gonna be twice your age right
she's 46 what up no okay no actually
it's 40 but you would have been wrong
but you weren't very we have you said 40
I know but you got to because I mean you
have to be firm in it you know if your
waves are now I gotta be firm in it
wait you screwed up the question in the
answer I'm you're probably in the little
teams at this point I'm okay with that
because C's get degrees Peyton all the
great you know
Marino Jim Kelly we didn't care about
any damn Wonderlic we're here to play
football that's right yeah ask Greg
McElroy how it feels to get a great
grade on the Wonderlic I
what are you doing beside the Peyton's
place places with Raymond Barrie I
really was touched by that I thought it
was wonderful you've done a great job
with it I just I mean you're gonna be 44
right that's coming up at what point do
you say I gotten what is my competitive
where's my competitive juices where are
they going to be flowing like what do
you want to do that really can anything
supplement playing quarterback in the
NFL what comes closest I'm not sure
there is to tell you the truth and I
think the fact at least I'm sort of
identified that that instead of looking
for something that's going to give you
that same rush of running out on the
field before a game or celebrating with
your teammates in the locker room I mean
it just doesn't get any any more of a
higher than that and I think trying to
chase that in sort of your check second
chapter can can be a mistake so I've
tried to find little things maybe a
combination of things that still keep me
stimulated keep me interested keep me
busy keep keep my kids seeing me working
whatever it is that I'm doing so but
it's you know being a part of different
projects with the NFL a number of
philanthropy project stand that I've
been heavily involved in and I kind of
find myself competing trying to raise
more money for the cause than we did the
year before
certainly my time with my family you
know even more sugar in this point in
time that that has been one of the
positives of it that you truly do get to
be together as a family no traveling
which it you know has been okay with me
so you know I I don't have all the
answers and I don't really use the
r-word everybody says how is retirement
I'm like I'm not sitting on my couch all
day but maybe I am now during the turn
of the quarantine but
to the most part I find myself kind of
busy and stimulated participating in a
lot of different projects and kind of a
part of a number of different teams if
you will and that's keeping me going and
I'm enjoying doing yeah I know that
there was the Monday Night Football talk
but you know that there will be other
jobs there that what I look forward to
seeing one day if it ever happens is a
camera behind the quarterback as he goes
to the line of scrimmage and you in real
time as an analyst saying you know hey I
see this there's the Mike linebacker
here now you see the free safety here
he's now this is where I would be I
change the play here this is what I
would like putting us in that moment as
no other quarterback has ever been able
to do in real time is the fascination
that I have with you as a broadcaster
you know you'll find you have enough
jobs here and doing enough things but
I'm selfishly I would hope one day to
see you do a game in real time live and
take us to the line of scrimmage well I
appreciate that the part is the
challenge is broadcasting and the ones
that are great at it like like Tony and
Cris Collinsworth and of course jump the
all-time great John Madden disabilities
to share all that information in five
seconds I could talk about a play for
you know two hours the same play I mean
I was watching I was rewinding over and
over again well you don't have two hours
so I'm not sure I'd be as good at it you
know knowing I only have five seconds to
talk about what a quarterbacks in the
line of scrimmage but I'd be glad to
seeing you like a like a long voice memo
or you know selfie video just kind of
talking through it I do have to share
that with you okay all right maybe just
one play a week you just say here Dan
here's your one play there you go I'd be
it and you could spend you know an hour
and a half two hours on that one play
and tell me everything you see there but
I I think it would be great
I really would and you know maybe I'm
being I am being selfish now I want to
give I want to send that card to Eli so
give me somebody to send it to because
the actual one that I'm just give me
your address on the air here and and
then I'll just send that I was joking
about that about giving your and it's uh
it's my I said - sure - uh sir - Mile
High Stadium
I want to make sure Li gets it okay oh
well I'll be sure I'm sure it's Eli is
uh breaking news you know he's got four
kids at home home schooling he is uh he
was coming out of retirement is he
willing to play for the Chargers now
that's how desperate he is to get out of
the house he'll play for the Chargers
once again it's fanatics calm the all in
challenge with Peyton Manning there's so
many great opportunities there auction
items there and Peyton congratulations
for what you've been doing and certainly
Peyton's places have been wonderful as
well
thanks Dan thanks for having me all you
got to stay healthy and stay safe it's
Peyton Manning